[Music]
we're gonna be doing something a little
different this week we're taking the
show on the road and doing this week's
interview in a remote studio joining me
is a personal hero of mine a former
guest on the Rubin report and now
someone that I'm incredibly proud to
call a friend
ayaan Hirsi Ali ion's life story is a
true testament to the human spirit which
shows that any of us including a little
girl born in Somalia who underwent
female genital mutilation can make
anything with their life and really show
what the human spirit is all about if
you want to test people and whether they
truly truly stand for liberalism
tolerance and Western values just ask
them what they think of ayaan Hirsi Ali
the people who really believed in the
individual and in human rights will be
firmly in her corner while those who
stand for moral relativism and
collectivist thinking will be against
her in an unfortunate sign of the times
speaking your mind as ayaan does comes
with a certain cost so unfortunately we
can't share the location of where we did
the interview but I do want to take a
moment and thank everyone who helped
facilitate it and without any further
ado here's my chat with ayaan Hirsi Ali
[Music]
all right we are on location this week
and I am with activist and author and
one of my favorite people on the planet
and now I can call you friend ayaan
Hirsi Ali welcome to the report
David thank you very much thank you for
having me some I can't believe that
somehow this is our first time sitting
down in person that's right we did it
over Skype a few times I guess yeah yeah
a lot of email yeah so I said to you
last night that what I don't want to do
today for this hour is just tell your
story again because it's been told so
many times it's an incredible story for
you it must be sort of exhausting to
tell it over and over and we'll link to
it below so that people can get it if
they don't know it but is there one
piece of your story that you think has
either been misconstrued or is or is an
important piece that people haven't
quite got or anything like that well
it's the reason why I tell it at all
which is I use it to illustrate that
it's possible you know to be born in
Africa grow up in a Muslim household and
go through all sorts of adversities and
come out whole and wholesome and healthy
and what I see sometimes what some of my
opponents use is they say oh she went
through all of these terrible things and
she's used she's angry she's resentful
she's miserable and so she's using Islam
to get back at an unhappy childhood and
I think that's false yeah and especially
now that I've gotten to know you a
little bit I don't sense any of that I
said I mean there's such light in you
and goodness and all of those things and
and I don't sense any of that but we're
sort of just stuck in a situation where
even by talking about this it's somehow
they want to project something on you
right that's right but I mean if you
look at the arguments of my opponents
what you see is they they run out of
logical consistence they they want to
defend a system of life or a theory for
life that is intolerant that is
anti-women
anti-gay that conflates religion with
politics and some of them really honest
ones defend it and go all the way to
you know this philosophy is better than
all other man-made philosophies and they
they talk good all the terrible stuff
that's the outcome but the ones who
believe in it and promote it and yet you
know find themselves in this what I what
I think of as cognitive dissonance yeah
they're the ones who would use anything
so fast they they say she has no
experience then I put my experience at
the table and they say okay that's bad
that's because you're traumatized things
are not in the Quran and I show them
what's in the Quran and they say yeah
you've misinterpreted or you know you're
doing something other than what it says
yeah and on and on and on it goes I
think it's just it's people who have no
argument or weak argument to take refuge
and just last night we spent some time
with some people that really had
interesting arguments and we didn't all
agree on things which I thought was was
wonderful and people people were quoting
the Quran and and all of this stuff and
and that's what discussion is about
which is why this whole thing is so
related to free speech and everything so
instead of talking about some of the
critics let's talk about your new your
new book should we call it a book or a
booklet or a what should we officially
call it oh it started out as a white
paper yeah it's now a booklet and I hope
to expand it to a book and you know
start treating other subjects such as a
simulation that are not in the booklet
but it's an argument it see I'm
basically saying in there that there's
this term Dawa and that non-muslims and
Muslims should know about I know that
most people here if you ask them about
jihad they they have something to say
about it they may not agree on what it
means but most people are familiar with
the term jihad right if you understand
you had to be a holy struggle or a holy
war against infidels against unbelievers
then that you have to understand that
there is this whole process that is
that's prior to jihad and that isn't our
yeah so when you talk about our well
you're really talking about it's
political Islam which is which is
separate it's not independent of but
it's separate than what we think of as
religious Islam right
yeah I think I like talking about
individuals because it's individuals who
take actions and then there is the
doctrine of Islam so I think from the
get-go you have to separate Islam as a
doctrine from Muslims as adherence and
Muslims do you ever feel that no matter
how much you do that that a certain set
of people just won't let you do that
because because I do it every week here
whenever we talk about this and a
certain amount of people just no matter
how many times you do that yeah they're
just they're not going to have it but
I'll keep doing it I think it's very
important to separate the doctrine from
the people and if you look at the
adherence what they do is they look at
the doctrine and they select out of the
doctrine what they want so if you look
at the Islamic doctrine Islamic history
Islamic scripture you will see that
politics and religion are intertwined
but there are many Muslims who just
stick to what is religious they'll say
look I pray I fast I would like to go to
a Mecca or they go to Mecca if they can
afford to but other than that there
really and the attitude toward other
people whether they're Muslims or
non-muslims in their Hillyer just
religious it is to say unto you your
religion or unto me mine right all of
this is in Islam yeah so for those
people I I like to describe them as
Mecca Muslims because what they're doing
is they're selecting out of that whole
doctrine the bits and pieces that were
revealed in Mecca to Muhammad so
Muhammad the founder of Islam when he
was met in Mecca he was saying certain
things he was behaving in a certain way
and there is that legacy and he likes to
stick to that Mecca Muslims how many
they are I can't tell you I think they
probably could be the largest number of
Muslims maybe they're decreasing in
number now because the other group the
medina Muslims the ones who look at
Muhammad's life and legacy and take
whatever it is that he established in
Medina which is heavy on politics heavy
on military those are Muslims that
engage in dower so so when we talk about
this Mecca and Medina stuff and the
history of this and all that do you
sometimes fear that by focusing too much
on that that we end up getting lost in
historical things that don't necessarily
tie us fully to what's happening
well there's always a risk of getting
lost in in history but I think in terms
of trying to differentiate because we
live it at a time when we really have to
make it very clear that not all Muslims
are dangerous or that not all Muslims
are a threat to us and in doing so you
have to fight you have to really mind
your language and you have to find ways
in separating those who are a potential
threat or are a threat and are Muslim
because you and I and I think many more
people now agree with us that some of
the phenomena of jihad we are seeing has
its roots in Islam if you believe that
it doesn't then you can go and get lost
in history and other discussions because
you always want to take the discussion
off the table right but if you if we all
agree so basically you can always find
some historical event to pin on instead
of what comes from doctor yeah so again
if we go back to you know let's look at
individuals which it's an individual who
takes part in discussions and there are
people who are taking part in this
discussion in the confrontation between
Islam and the West and Islam in the rest
of the world and who just happened to
believe is Lomb as a religion as a
doctrine has nothing to do with what we
are seeing Islam has nothing to do with
Isis or al-qaeda or Boko Haram or
al-shabaab with terrorism with jihad
with misogyny none of that work and I
think it's very I don't know about you
but I I it's very difficult for me to
talk about this subject with those
people yeah because I feel like their
job is to deflect and mine is to
eliminate as much as possible and I
think it's helpful if we can pinpoint
exactly what it is about Islam that we
don't like and that's a threat and more
importantly who are the Muslims who are
seeking to use Islam as a tool for
political power for domination for
misogyny and to justify the
unjustifiable throwing people from tall
places to their death
killing and enslaving women
regurgitating anti-semitism you know we
thought with after 1945 at the end of
the Second World War that there was this
enormous insight in the West
no more anti-semitism never again and
now it's become if you I don't know how
often you visit or go to Europe but in
Europe anti-semitism is back and it's
back because of Islam yeah so ok so
there's there's a bunch there so when
people talk about these books one of the
things that I'll hear people say as well
wait a minute the the Old Testament has
a ton of bad stuff in it yes
I suspect you wouldn't disagree with
that the New Testament actually has less
bad out of the three if you were looking
them in terms of violence I think the
New Testament is certainly the least
violent of the three but what is the
difference then that that makes the
individuals act on one of them more than
the others is it just that this is the
newest one and it hasn't gone through
that Reformation or that maturation or
whatever else or is it specifically yeah
the the point of the text well I think
historically if you if you look at the
history of Christianity you'll see that
there's been a lot of internal fighting
about what Christianity should mean in
the place of the Old Testament the place
of the New Testament there was this
whole process of Reformation the
Enlightenment and beyond even
post-modernism is part of you know the
place of Christianity and one of the
things that I think made it easier for
Christians to move forward was that from
the get-go politics and religion were
separate so you couldn't be declared not
to be Christian if you've proposed or
you're a proponent of manmade laws and
rules with Islam we're not yet there and
there have been individuals in the
history of Islam who fought for a
separation of religion from politics
they have all been marginalized they
have been forgotten by most Muslims they
are celebrated only by non-muslims in
the Christian world but they have
they've unto this day there are Muslims
I
call them performance I call them
modifies it's about that group you know
this the mecca the medina and the
modifiers right to this day you have
these Muslims who wants to modernize who
want to liberalize who want to move
forward and who wants to you know say
let's just separate politics from
religion so that no one no religious
person uses Islam as a tool for
political domination but again they're
marginalized their side like they're
threatened so is this the ultimate
failing of what the the frustrations
that we and many others have with the
left that they have actually held Islam
hostage in a weird way because every
time someone comes out and says I want
to reform the faith or you know what
Maajid Nawaz is trying to do with
Quilliam Foundation and many other
people now and unfortunately as we were
talking about you know there is a
growing movement there but every time
they they step out of that Lane yeah
they get slammed so it really it's the
it's the Liberals unfortunately the left
yeah that is holding the more extreme
elements of Islam in power I think that
a part of it of course yeah so there's
there's the internal dynamics of Islam
and Muslims and how they fight out
what's to retain of Islam and what not -
yeah and then there are the external
pressures and I think what when we talk
about because this is really relevant
for Muslims living inside Western
countries with a left and a right where
the left find themselves I just want to
say inadvertently I can't believe that
they really mean it that they're doing
this consciously and willingly yeah but
they find themselves in a battle II
aligned whether it is lowest I've heard
some people say that's because the left
hates America the left hates capitalism
the left can't deal with political
freedom and to find another group with a
similar outlook even though they want to
set a different outcome right that it's
easy very natural for the far left to
align itself not only with Islam and
Islamism but also with other radical
anti Western movements and this is
basically what intersectionality is
right
oppressed groups that are coming
together and these quote-unquote
oppressed groups that are coming
together to form something bigger even
if they're their own what they want at
the end of the day is actually very
different when I look at people talk
about intersectionality and and all you
know this whole identity politics thing
what I see is taking the human being
magnifying a biological attribute and
then putting them aside putting them in
a corner as victims of oppression and in
a way I feel sorry for them I happen to
be black and I happen to be a woman and
I happen to be a minority in the United
States
I even happened to be an apostate so
talk about intersectionality yeah
but none of that defines me as Who I am
I'm more than all of that and I must
certainly don't see myself as a victim
and knowing people who grew up in Africa
who grew up in Muslim countries you
probably know also some gay people who
had to struggle and go through adversity
I think when you come out of it you come
out as a proud survivor you don't come
out as a victim and you don't want to be
victimized you don't want safe spaces
you don't want to be in this constant
mental state of anger and full of
resentment and wanting to lash out at
others and demanding that society or
whoever it is that you feel oppresses
you gives you money and jobs and no you
come out of this thinking you know I've
earned I love to work you know I what
I'm proud of in my journey is that I was
able to say if every time when I tried
to run away from that husband yeah some
of the Somalis around me would say
you're going to rot in hell and there's
absolutely no way you're going to
survive outside of the extended family
the clan you will end up being a [ __ ]
you learn and now at the age of 47 I
want to look back and tell them
didn't happen yeah I didn't end up being
a [ __ ] I don't think I'm going to burn
in hell because I don't believe there's
a hell and I have a wonderful
comfortable life that I couldn't have if
I had gone with that man yeah that
doesn't make me into a victim
intersectionality or no
intersectionality yeah so to me the
whole thing the whole hogwash of the
language I try to go through some of
these articles and books and they're so
boring yeah it's just one long excuse to
wallow in self-pity and that's not they
don't those people don't speak for all
blacks for all women for all minorities
they just speak for in my view a very
small subsection of over privileged
individuals who yeah who are seeking to
take advantage of the trend now of white
guilt yeah so is the irony that it may
not even be exactly what you say that is
getting for the for your critics it's
not exactly what you're saying which if
you've probably whittled it down they
might agree with you on some of it
privately at least but it's that you
don't act like a victim and they can't
that is so counter yeah to the entire
movement that even if they you could get
them to privately say you know yeah
you're making some good points but that
your your very existence as a free
functioning happy successful person yeah
is counter to their movement and that's
more of a threat than whatever you can
say about Islam or anything else that's
a threat and the leadership within this
movement I have no idea what to call
them you brought up the term
intersection or they called
intersectional god knows what they're
called they love the oppression Olympics
which I heard first from our friend
Faisal what some of it I mean look at
college campuses there are freshmen
young vulnerable students impressionable
minds and their heads are filled with
these nonsense that you know they have
to fear for their lives and that they're
not safe on campus and American campuses
and it's that kind of leadership that I
find so toxic because here you have
young people in my view I mean I come
from Africa people would kill to be in
winning any
yeah universities and get an education
yeah and here they are being told that
if they read Plato or Shakespeare or
Mark Twain they're threatened somehow
yeah that there's rape culture there
this I you know what are you doing to
these young people yeah
so we're with that where do you think
the fault lies because I agree with you
I think a lot of the people that are
that have bought into these ideas I
don't blame the the eighteen-year-old
kid who has been hit with this stuff and
indoctrinated I don't blame that kid
yeah I would hopefully we'll fight to
save some of their intellect at some
point hopefully they'll hear some of our
good ideas but who do you blame do you
blame the administrators first you and
we're putting these stupid programs
together and I think those programs
should not be funded and of course the
administrators the faculty you you you
blame the people who are supposed to be
the grown-ups in the room and for them
to you know sign off on these programs
where young people are being scared to
death on campuses and it's not here's
the paradox the people that they are
supposed to protect and one is feeling
protective of other ones who get
disadvantaged ultimately because you and
you make people seen nothing else but
their skin color or nothing else but
their gender or their transgendered Ness
or whatever it is other biological
attribute and for four years or five
years you're in a setting where your
demands are met or supposedly met I
think usually people just ignore it
right which would be the best thing to
do actually I think you would think that
but then you you graduate and then you
go into you start taking part in real
life and then I wonder what has this
institution of learning and Dan for
these young people what what has it done
to them yeah so if you were advising a
school that was going through this where
every week we see another school going
through this and there there's the you
know they want a professor fired they
wanted administrator fired what would
you say to them is that I mean okay so
we can defund some of this stuff but is
it really that we have to teach courses
on this I mean teach the reverse course
they're learning identity pilot
do we need a counter course yes we need
an you know individuality courses we
need more courses on the American
Constitution you know the individuals
who founded this country in the
adversities that they went through I
would propose more programs on Western
civilization what makes it distinct from
other civilizations from other cultures
and I would most definitely emphasize
when it comes to freedom the position of
the individual not groups not
individuals you can pretend you are in
some kind of group with all black people
but that's not the case you are an
individual and your circumstances are
different from other peoples and I think
when you want you know people say well
if you're going through the same sort of
suffering or through the same kind of
adversity it does help to organize and
it does most certainly and to put on the
table exactly what it is that these
problems are and together to work out as
a group but the members in that group
are voluntary yeah they actually say you
know I'm working with some Muslim women
who understand that Sharia as a system
of law is really something that's
applied to their daily lives that
compromises their freedom compromises
their dignity and as a group they don't
see themselves as victims of anything
else other than this particular culture
that's practiced by their own parents
their own extended family their own
community and they wanted to change and
they want to change these communities
but outside of that outside of those few
hours when they're highlighting these
issues there are three individuals going
about their daily lives
[Music]
you